congresswoman alexandria ocasio-cortez
is calling for the expulsion of
republicans involved in the planning of
the trump riot we now have as we talked
about in the last segment um the
allegations from two slash three sources
who spoke to hunter walker for rolling
stone about the involvement of marjorie
taylor green madison cawthorne lauren
bobert paul gosar louis gohmert andy
biggs uh maybe i'm forgetting one in the
planning of the january 6th protests
which turned riotous alexandria
ocasio-cortez now says anybody who's
involved should be uh kicked out of the
house of representatives kicked out of
congress newsweek reporting
congresswoman alexandria ocasio-cortez
called for the expulsion of any member
of congress who helped plan the storming
of the u.s capitol after a bombshell
report alleged that several republican
lawmakers had coordinated with rally
organizers
her comment came after a rolling stone
report published sunday night claimed
multiple members had been intimately
involved in the planning of former
president donald trump's efforts to
overturn his election loss and the
january 6 protests which culminated in
the violence at the u.s capitol she
tweeted quote any member of congress who
helped plot a terrorist attack on our
nation's capital must be expelled this
was a terror attack 138 injured almost
10 dead those responsible remain a
danger to our democracy our country and
human life in the vicinity of our
capital and beyond now i would actually
go a step further
expulsion actually isn't enough
aoc
can only deal with the expulsion part
because she's not law enforcement she's
a legislator but it actually isn't
enough
we should be talking about criminal
charges here if applicable
when the evidence points to that what i
mean is there should not be a no
criminal charges now
because these are members of congress it
needs to be looked at as if these were
any other people now realistically we're
not going to see the expulsion aoc is
right we should see it we're not going
to see it it would take a two-thirds
vote
um
to expel any member
this will never happen given the narrow
margins instead what probably needs to
happen
is the prosecution needs to happen and
then
that will make these folks
ineligible in theory if convicted and
immediately removed it's easier i
believe to convince i don't know if it
would be six people if these would be
12 12 percent probably 12 person juries
although you know it depends on a lot a
lot of particulars it's easier to
convince 12 people
uh off the street than it would be to
convince
highly partisan actors in the house of
representatives to vote to expel their
own to their own detriment by flipping
the balance of power further uh against
their own party so that that's just a
reality aoc completely right
we are only in stage like 0.1 in
figuring out what the fallout and what
the repercussions are going to be from
these incredible allegations based on
this rolling stone piece by hunter
walker but aoc completely right
law enforcement and the justice system
needs to be ready to go as well these
people deserve to go down for this and
one of the real problems that makes me
worried there's likely to be more of
this the next time they don't like an
election result is that there have not
been serious consequences yes we started
to see some verdicts and okay there are
people who are going to have to do a few
years
but for
the political figures involved
no consequences whatsoever and uh we're
going to now see if this will push
things over the edge we know that this
congressional committee has been
investigating and looking at this
evidence but is law enforcement looking
at it is the department of justice
looking at it joe biden shouldn't get
involved the way he hasn't but it should
be looked at we're going to follow it
let me know your thoughts about all of
this
via twitter where you can find me at d
pacman on twitter